so contact tracing really is a key
component to try and stop the spread
but it's been challenging as 8 news now
reporter kristen drummond shows us
not everybody is forthcoming the
southern nevada health district works
with
various community partners when it comes
to contact tracing
those involved say it's working despite
some issues
it's not a perfect system brian labis
oversees the contact tracing program at
unlv
it's all run by students and they're
working every day to
investigate cases here in southern
nevada a rewarding but challenging job
according to the assistant professor at
the school of public health
especially now as covet cases spike when
we're
having a lot of transmission in the
community contact phrasing is not as
useful in stopping disease transmission
as we get things under control the
usefulness increases as well because
then we can track down every one of
those cases
the southern nevada health district says
more positivity rates means
the potential to delay sharing
information it's hard to make sure that
just those cases have been notified of
their diagnosis but also to collect all
the information of context that requires
people to remember
and share their contacts names and
numbers but some choose to withhold
those details we have people who will
not tell us where they were or not tell
us who they were around and there's not
much we can do in that situation
the state division of public and
behavioral health reports traditional
contact tracing helps identify about 25
percent of cases
only a quarter of nevada's population
but efforts by unlv students assist with
reducing the spread
as much as possible kristin drummond 8
news now
so to try and identify the other 75
percent of cases and also to reduce that
exposure
uh the state is actually encouraging
everyone to download that covid trace
nevada app
but so far just four percent of the
population has downloaded it in order
for it to be effective
at least 15 percent need to start using
it on their phones